élan bonjour guten tag cher petit ami je
me baladais hier sur les réseaux sociaux
comme chaque jour beaucoup trop
d'ailleurs il faut que j'arrête il faut
arrêter ça et je vois plusieurs
personnes qui me mentionne et qui me
balance un lien d'une vidéo et qui me
disent lucas il faut que vous allez voir
ça et je vous assure que ça n'arrive pas
si souvent que ça je me dis [ __ ] moi
c'est bizarre est ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui parle de moi qui m'a cléac'h et en
vidéo qui a fait une réponse à ce coup
dit pas du tout aujourd'hui 2 qui
s'appelle est-ce que squeeze est parfait
sur la chaîne s'appelle photoshop soeur
john key à presque 1 million d'abonnés
et je me dis mais déjà qu'est ce que je
fous sur cette chaîne comment le garde
lui parler de moi c'est très bizarre à
ce moment là je ne sais pas encore ce
que c'est que cette chaîne et je regarde
la vidéo c'est un mec et sur photoshop
il applique un masque sur ton visage et
il photoshop ta gueule pour voir la
toiture semblerait si tu avais un visage
aux proportions parfaites youri bhl
laisse mes promotions imparfaite
tranquille mais t'es qui toi au monde
est bien français bien gros je lève je
l'apprécient fait partie de moi est mon
histoire
bref il fait ça pendant toute la vidéo
bon du coup on est d'accord on aurait
tous aimé qu'il fasse la même chose sur
sur la chouette mais n'a pas fait à la
fin regardez sur reveal mecs vous allez
taper une barre en voyant ma vraie tête
ça c'est horrible ce mec a rendu ma
vraie tête
ridicule regardez
je pars est difforme je peux pas vous
dire bien il met tellement des
imperfections en avant que ça devient
des complexes regarder mon menton n'ai
pas droit mon nez est un peu de travers
et il et il est de taille conséquent
j'ai un sourcier can am en plus haut que
l'autre et 1,9 à d'après lui mais est ce
important il ya beaucoup de gens qui me
charest sur ça mais pour l'auteur ça ça
n'a pas bougé déjà aimé surtout barème
maven elle est toujours là je suis
désolé je suis désolé de vous
l'apprendre le visage modèle il assure
lui la veine de squeeze voix c'est comme
ça vous n'y pouvait rien devant voilà
c'est une chaîne qui appliquent ce
fameux masque aux proportions parfaites
sur plein de gens par exemple robert
downey junior qu'on lui a plus que le
masque ce qui se passe donc notre dieu à
tous robert downey junior s'il vous
plaît en respectant l'applaudît bien
faire chez soi et il en a absolument
rien à [ __ ] oui c'est ça il est déjà
parfait qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
elle va regarder si on respecte ces
fameuses proportions parfaites il
devient sa nanny regardez il est
tellement mieux à droite mais qu'elle a
tellement plus de charisme mais
tellement plus humain il est tellement
plus fin mais quand vous appliquez ces
proportions parfaites sur le visage ça
donne quelqu'un qui ne fait pas une main
tellement les proportions sont
inhabituellement on ne voit jamais ça
sur le visage d'un humain ça n'existe
pas sauf si vous avez fait énormément de
chirurgie esthétique c'est inconfortable
de voir un visage comme ce mec à gauche
c'est pour moi c'est inconfortable
n'empêche je le prends bien il a fait ça
sur robert downey junior et après il
s'est dit on va faire ce squeeze
merci et sur une femme je monte sur par
exemple
emma roberts mdr qu'est ce que tu veux
améliorer ça me tue de faire ça sur des
gens qui sont déjà trop connu parce
qu'ils sont canon ça me fait trop marrer
ça n'a aucun sens à eva moi ça me fait
peur là l'image des goûts en fait on
dirait vraiment un humanoïde tsar de
personnes dans laquelle on a mis un
cerveau mais qui a encore deux robots a
joué ça me met pas bien quoi
bref je me suis donc renseigné sur ceux
des vers la du visage parfait des
proportions parfaites j'ai découvert des
choses vachement intéressante pour ça je
trouve cette vidéo d'art il qu'est ce
que j'en dis d'ailleurs deux mois à tous
les coups ça va le passionné il va faire
des recherches sur les retouches ou et
la perfection humaine et dans quelques
semaines on a une vidéo l'humain parfait
existe-t-il annonce carrément mal mais
peut être pas c'est exactement ça qui
s'est passé ça me fait chier kelvin mpm
et c'est ça je me suis dit [ __ ] mais
c'est quoi ce délire de proportion et
donc je tombais sur cet article qui
parle de la symétrie et des proportions
du visage parfait dont beaucoup roulent
à toute heure de proportions la longueur
entre l'intérieur de l'oeil et
l'extrémité du sourcil la longueur entre
l'extrémité du sourcil et le milieu de
lorient auteur enfin on arrive à des
conclusions comme la hauteur verticale
d'un visage aux proportions parfaites
nous est évalué en divisant le visage
dans des tiers égaux et si toi tu as des
trucs qui dépasse dans un autre tiers
etc
c'est ton visage n'est pas parfait
autant vous dire qu'ici on a tous le
visage pas parfait c'est terrible mais
c'est vraiment scientifique quoi les
proportions parfaites du visage humain
c'est ça alors déjà j'ai mal car j'ai
découvert que je n'étais pas parfait ça
fait mal à l'école j'ai donc creuser le
truc voir si d'autres gens avaient fait
une étude sur les proportions parfaites
d'un visage humain et c'est ce qui est
très glauque 1 je trouve hélas un
photographe qui répondait au nom non pas
de blâmer de scotch à ce rookie s'est
interrogé sur ce qu'on aimerait changer
chez nous pour être plus beau et oui
c'est bel et bien le titre de l'article
que je suis en train de vous lire je ne
fais même pas l'effort de trouver des
synonymes
et figurez-vous que souvent la version
originale est beaucoup mieux que la
retoucher ouf
et ça aussi vous l'avez deviné c'était
la suite du titre et donc certaines
personnes n'aiment pas leur visage pour
x raisons on a tous nos petits complexes
c'est normal
moi par exemple j'ai le sourcil très
haut je suis un peu affaissé la bla bla
bla bon je m'en fous un peu mais je sais
que c'est des imperfections c'est ce que
j'appelle des imperfections et donc lui
sediba vous savez quoi je vais
photoshopée une photo de vous pour faire
de votre visage un visage qui répond
proportions parfaites on va vous montrer
une seconde chaque photo donc la photo
sans le photo chauffage et la photo a
pris le photoshop âge et on va voir
instinctivement laquelle vous avez
préféré en mesure votre activité
cérébrale et dans 100% des cas les gens
ont toujours préféré la photo de
partouche est donc celle où
à leurs imperfections et le message il
est super beau ce à quoi vous ressemblez
actuellement sera toujours plus beau
qu'un vous qu on perfectionne en faisant
des proportions parfaites etc voilà
c'est un petit message que je trouve
bien que c'est la fin de la vidéo
pas du tout bref tout ça pour vous dire
que ce délire des proportions parfaites
et du visage parfait c'est un pur
fantasme
voilà maintenant vous avez quand même
envie de savoir si votre visage
répondent plus ou moins à ces fameuses
proportions parfaites j'ai donc trouvé
un outil qui va vous dire si votre
visage est parfait ou pas aux yeux de la
science ça s'appelle suis-je beaux ou
moches le cloud 0 effort de la part des
créateurs c'est horrible test en ligne
qui analyse votre beauté analysé notre
visage en trois minutes et vous donne
une note entre 1 et 100 et ce qui reste
quand vous démarrez t 5e un petit
message d'avertissement attention si
vous avez peu d'estimé de vous et des
problèmes de confiance en vous s'il vous
plaît ne faites pas ce test mais maigre
regarde ce que tu as marqué dans la page
juste avant c'est facile de mettre ça
derrière à les mecs qui viennent leur
dire est ce que vous êtes beau vous est
moche on va vous dire de mon choisy une
petite photo d'armand j'en étais chargé
une exprès pour pour ce fameux test je
n'ai pas fait encore donc je vais
découvrir même temps que vous mais bon
je me doute du [ __ ] de résultats vu la
gueule qui m'a fait l'autre dans sa
vidéo salut c'est et squeeze ça va vous
ok aubin lé jani khel dedans ça sent bon
ça moi je vous le dire ok ensuite vous
placez du coût des trucs à certains
endroits et des bien entendu ça dure
milan mais qd façon je me doute du
résultat alsace trop ils vont donner une
baisse de note est l'hôte avec sa vidéo
on lui aura prouvé qu'il a tort
80% vous êtes bon allez on pas méprenez
pas prenez pas les résultats du test
rompre au sérieux c'est juste un test à
la con mais mais bon apparemment je suis
beau une bonne forme de visage une
taille de front normal il complètement
dépassée la russie admet qu vraiment ce
fronton prof de français il peut écrire
dessus pour pour faire ses courses et
une ardoise et j'ai une bonne un visage
at bien symétrique
franchement non vraiment pas j'ai
vraiment une partie visage qui
s'affaisse comme beaucoup beaucoup de
gens belge pas quoi c'est d'ailleurs
cette mort cérébral ont vu bon bah
écoutes je suis pas peu fier mais je
n'ai pas eu 100%
et ça ça qu'on à l'égo de l'uqam hochart
ça fait mal et c'est là qu'intervient
deuxième site que j'ai trouvé qu'ils
s'appellent pink mirror points comme on
va lui donner l'une de nos photos et il
va modifier d'un visage pour que notre
visage soit parfait selon lui ayew
il fait tout tout seul waouh [ __ ] ils
sont fait chier américain pour montrer
aux gens à quel point ils sont moches
ils ont mis les moyens en place à ok
avant après celle blague
tu te fous de ma gueule tu viens juste
de mettre un filtre instagram pour y
étudier que j'ai des proportions
parfaites sénat mais à ok en fait ils
ont juste mais une correction pour y est
c - qui doit choisir les modifs pour ma
note augmente crois que c'est ça en fait
une sorte de jeu quoi assailli ça
consomme modifié là ça commence à
modifier l'âge devient un extraterrestre
mais c'est chiant il va me le faire tout
seul
trop schirmeck attend si je mets tout
comme axa me vois comme gueule si je
mets toutes leurs options là de
tricheurs au max dans la nature m'a
donné le maxi pouvoir de la beauté
comment je suis non mais gros là c'est
bien là c'est bien si si tu veux mettre
un pied dans une bouteille mais
l'entonnoir c'est cool mais en terme de
beauté on y est vraiment merdé attentes
en attend autant gêner dès 6h je le
remets dans l'autre site qui me dit si
je suis parfait ou non attends non si je
prends le mec là de la vidéo qui m'a
rendu parfait et que le résultat je le
mets dans ce site là est ce que il a une
meilleure note que moi lui alors qu'il
est retouché à la chaussée à faire
remonter mon ego j'aurai une meilleure
confiance en moi un mec je n'ai pas
besoin de bouger les lignes ils sont
placés par défaut bord 91 % ok ok
attendant regardez combien on les potes
youtuber désolé j'ai envie du coup de
maître toute la planète dans ce test
c'est horrible à ce que je fais c'est
rien quelle est ta note mon ami quelle
est ta note pour la c6 prix jeunes mais
ce marabout ça marche tu vas y basé mon
pote ce que je suis plus beau que toi
cyprien qui est le plus gros de nous
63% alors sa bravoure 13 millions
d'abonnés
le pourcentage de beauté il est moins
élevé que ce oui alors le mec le trophée
de sa live c'est d'avoir eu 80% sur ce
site c'est la plus belle chose qui soit
arrivée de toute sa vie
bon j'aimerais qu'on teste autre chose
maintenant j'aimerais qu'on rende mon
visage parfaitement symétrique en fait
je crois que quand un visage est très
symétriques c'est très perturbant parce
qu'il ya quasiment aucun visage qui est
symétrique on a tous des petites
asymétrie en ayant un peu plus ma claude
a sorti un peu plus le clou dans mon cas
c'est jamais parfaitement semaine j'ai
envie de tester sur moi même et on va
voir si c'est troublant ou pas bon je
suis juste allé à la salle musée
symétrique juste grave à la salle vidéo
de même au delà du fait qu'on dirait que
tu allais 600 jours à la salle d'affilée
tous les jours quatre fois c'est
vraiment bizarre en fait j'ai compris
après multitude d'expériences que nous
venons de faire ensemble
aujourd'hui d'un truc c'est que quand
quelqu'un a un visage parfaitement
symétrique ou un visage qui répondent
aux proportions parfaites et ben c'est
juste récent et si c'est pas beau on
dirait des cyborgs et des trucs pas
vivant n'ya pas d'expressions n'y a pas
de c'est très bizarre donc la morale ce
sont vos imperfections qui font de vous
quelqu'un de beau voilà non mais
vraiment c'est ça tous ces petits trucs
que vous trouvez hommes ont ils un peu
gros à mon front chebah quoi bref tous
ces trucs là que vous et moi on peut
s'imaginer à propos de notre visage
et bien en fait ça fait partie de nous
et ça nous rend vraiment boké beau c'est
pas les proportions mathématiques etc
c'est ce que dégage une personne dans
ses attitudes dans sa manière de parler
dans son vécu coup qu'on peut voir sur
son visage
bref toutes ces choses là sont très
belles sur les humains oui il ya bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo j'espère c'est
ça vous a plu
reposez vous bien qui fait bien fait ça
mais tu vas gallo sortira cette vidéo
passer une bonne soirée tout du moins et
puis à bientôt
au revoir tout le monde connaît la dire
qu'on visage il est pas parfait va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]